One of the ideas behind Servant is that
we never leave
the brownstone on Spruce Street.
And that was the conceit, give it
this kind of suffocating feeling.
So episode one of season three,
where Leanne goes outside
for the first time,
is something I really
looked forward to directing
because it's a very Hitchcockian
sequence of paranoia.
It's her trying to overcome
her almost crippling anxiety
about going outside.
From the beginning,
when you see her from behind,
she's gathering her strength.
She wanted this life.
She wanted to stay in this brownstone,
but she knows that
something dark's coming for her.
So, can she even enjoy this anymore?
All she's ever wanted to be
is this normal girl in this family.
Can I just take a walk down the street?
We had to go through the wall,
and we actually did go through the wall,
to kind of come on the outside
and then dip down and then zoom in.
This is a much harder shot than it looks.
All the sound effects explode,
and the room is filling up
with her paranoia.
Just each step, with this
wide-angle lens, this sense of like,
it's very hard to walk, just keep going,
and her forcing herself to go forward.
Leanne keeps looking around
over her shoulder
to see if anybody's gonna
run up behind her and attack her.
And we're doing very close shots,
so you can see her face is warping
with how wide our lens is.
And it's like, keep getting
closer to her, closer to her,
so she's feeling suffocated,
even though she's outside.
There's this stranger
that looks awfully like Uncle George,
the person that attacked her
in season two.
And she's watching him and going,
"Why is he standing there?"
Meanwhile, Julian's trying
to break up with her
over her shoulder.
She's sick of being told what to do.
And she finds her strength here.
This is what this frame is.
The walking stops, and now
she's gonna go and be a different person.
-And now it's time I think we--
-No.
She feels foolish, and she's like,
"I can't be normal out here."
And so she grabs the baby,
and she's very upset.
Julian's outside, and then you see...
Boom...
the house starting to fall apart.
The house and her are kinda tied,
and as she gets angry
and feels certain emotions,
the house manifests that.
I found this episode
so scary and unnerving,
and leans into the things
that I'm passionate about,
which is paranoia and suspense,
and like, kinda that wink
as we kind of tumble into
darker and darker things for Leanne.